[Música]
ora é e é essa é em 2002 e eu é tipo daí
pra frente como mulher a dona na frente
de um escritório ser fera
então eu fiz o meu primeiro concurso
sozinha e falei vou ter que ganhar esse
concurso é mostrar que eu sou capaz e eu
ganhei e daí pra frente eu fiquei bem
sossegada para poder projetar com
certeza que as coisas iam rolar muito
bem e temos vários várias encomendas e
os clientes sempre coloca na sua mão
os ideais que eles têm são casas várias
coisas que a gente faz muitas vezes
acaso casa porque fazer uma casa e acho
que você vai consertar a vida deles é
impossível a prefeitura ela ajuda mas às
vezes também quando você faz uma obra
para um casal por uma casa você até
desmanchar casamento já aconteceu comigo
essa capela que era o anseio de uma
sociedade que nasceu de uma tragédia é
uma capela e mariana que é ficava fica
no morro de go go que é amor de
mineração tem mais de mil buracos de
mineração nasce não pode andar na ser um
guia e essa capela um dia ela era de
século 18 ela sumiu ela foi abduzida da
noite para o dia a comunidade acordou
onde estava a capela foi vendida à
comunidade é sem saber perdeu a capela
de santana que era que a onde eles
faziam as festas os batizados onde eles
se reuniam e me pediram para refazer a
capela difícil porque uma capela do
século 18 você não vai refazer com o
mesmo material nem com a mesma
tecnologia
já eles trazia capela de volta em forma
de alma isto é uma capela que era é
cheia de retalhos porque ela foi
recuperada com a empresa quebrou
entregou todo material para a ufmg então
tinha aquela quantidade enorme de peças
nós fizemos um levantamento de todas as
peças grande parte não pertencia a ela
porque pertence a outras capelas que
essa mesma empresa comprou e desmontou e
montou na sede um frankstein
estou e vários pedaços de várias capelas
e eu tive que fazer uma prospecção uma
profunda pesquisa para saber aquilo que
participava da capela
isso foi o que sobrou do terreno da
capelinha de santana
então a minha proposta era fazer uma
nova arquitetura em cima dessa eu fiz um
levantamento disso fiz isso junto com
altino que o professor da escola que puc
na arquitetura
fizemos um levantamento vasto muito
amplo e em cima da ruína
nós construímos a mesma igreja a mesma
volumetria mas não tínhamos nenhum
documento nenhuma foto da época apenas
uma pequena foto de um jornal e fizemos
através de escala como que poderia ter
sido aquela capela no dia
então ela tinha essa no metrô dia isto é
isso é uma pesquisa que nós fizemos em
cima de jornal está a foto de jornal
como tinha uma pessoa na foto a gente
conseguiu escalar em relação a essa
pessoa então aqueles elementos que
participaram um dia da capela do século
a gente voltou com ela para os lugares e
aqui tem um corte como ela seria na
parte dela de volumetria a plantinha que
nós temos então a nave quadro a nave ea
capela mor ea única coisa que eu
conseguia saber se realmente estava
dentro da volumetria seria o arco
cruzeiro que é uma peça importante
que separa a capela mor da da nave e
quando fizemos um corte e colocamos o
levantamento do arco ele como serginho
ele cobriu exato no lugar onde ele foi
isso a gente chama de ananás to lose
colocar um elemento antigo na
arquitetura nova dentro da mesma escala
só que a capela que eu trouxe ela tem a
mesma identidade da capela antiga porém
ela completamente seu andamento
eu não poderei repetir os ornamentos
porque seria salvo demais ea eu queria
trazer na verdade a alma da capelinha e
alma e despojada de ornamentos
então aqui nós temos as visões criei um
museu com as peças que sobraram que não
era dela também aqui são corte aqui o
arco cruzeiro encaixou certinho no corte
as fachadas laterais limpa simples toda
ela feita em concreto branco sem nada
nada nada nem o andamento
aqui ela fica no morro e tem essa vista
maravilhosa então o altar mor
a gente deixou em vidro que voltar seria
a paisagem das montanhas de minas
a capela então ficou com esse jeito e
mostrei para a comunidade tem uma
comunidade 1500 pessoas
eles aprovaram esse projeto mas
infelizmente está engavetado já tem os
oito anos que foi feito e não foi feita
eu estou a conseguir trazer para eles a
alma da capela é o que deu a eles assim
o novo alento de uma nova casa pra eles
e tem uma segunda capela que também
mariana pela tragédia da barragem de
bento rodrigues que há a essa capelinha
advento rodrigues que ela foi devastada
ficou só para a vizinha é essa primeira
peladinha baixa ela linda a cidadezinha
hoje não existe mais está debaixo de
lama
os elementos artísticos foram todos
embora com a lama aqui está o lugar da
capela que ficava aqui no meio da lama
aqui já é a a as estampas que ficaram
porque as campas não foram levadas
embora onde tinha sido enterradas
pessoas
então a minha ideia foi proteger tudo
isso tudo que estava ainda lá a queda
pouco e trazer algumas peças que eram
realmente é que foram captadas no meio
da lama lá longe no rio
nós limpamos é preservamos as peças e
fizemos a proposta de construir uma
capela quase como se fosse um bunker que
a comunidade até hoje presencia as
festas lá que é um volume todo de
concreto como se fosse um bunker
concreto feito com a própria lama de
mariana e essas partes faltantes são
parques que serão construídas
ela seria um retângulo perfeito as
partes cortadas serão peças sejam
construídas nos outros distritos para
servir de referência a esse desastre
aconteceu em 2015 mariana a parte
posterior da capela internamente
eu usei a contra a forma para fazer a
capela então você não vê a capela do
lado de fora você tem que entrar pra
gente a ambiência da capelinha que seria
aquela usando concreto ea contra a forma
do concreto e sempre com iluminações e
metais sobre o teto
aqui há a as campas que bom que
permanecem não podem ser mexidos não
pode pisotear então temos uma rampa e
vai levando as pessoas para conhecer
todo o espaço aqui é um testemunho que
ficou teve que ficar um pedaço da lama
que ficou que já é à vista além de rampa
é o museu
nós vamos trabalhar com as peças que
foram recolhidas como roupas sapatos
livros tudo aquilo que ficou no bairro e
que viraram peças é rígidas é
endurecidas com a própria lama que
ficariam todas ali como
11 o inventário da população da
comunidade voltar a minha proposta do
altar era refazer voltar a pilotar foi
embora com a lama era refazer o altar
todo e lama com um artista excelente que
nós encontramos lá em mariana e as peças
que teriam sido salvas serão colocadas
nos lugares onde estiveram antes
bom então é que os que prazer com essas
duas capelinhas
é o tipo de coisa que acontece na vida
do arquiteto ea os anseios da população
que eles trazem para você
no caso das duas que foram vítimas de
tragédia uma foi roubada ea outra foi
levada pela lama é você recuperar os
espaços perdidos que era importante para
a religião e religiosidade para as
reuniões e comunidade são sempre
comunidades muito simples muito pobres e
que esperam que um dia e não seja
recuperado
as duas estão engavetadas hessen ainda
nenhuma perspectiva de construção ea
comunidade que almeja isso pressiona
diretamente às empresas e não
conseguimos colocar em pé ainda mas eu
queria só mostrar a vocês como é
possível recuperar a memória de uma
coisa que existiu e que você utilizava
você pode respeitosamente sem fazer o
fake de novo trazer o monumento trazer
aconchego ea religiosidade ser ali de
novo embutida na na comunidade
então são propostas é é é conceituais
mais conceituais e nós estamos
aguardando então agora uma resposta das
autoridades para ver se essas tragédias
desgraças trazem ainda de volta se
possível ambientes e lugares que um dia
foram é isto obrigada
[Aplausos]